welcome back to las vegas now if you're
selling property harvey blankfeld
wants to remind you about the importance
of disclosures inspections and repairs
here's more information welcome to our
show this is las vegas real estate now
where we bring you the three e's educate
empower and engage we want to help you
to make your real estate decisions wise
ones for you and your family i'm your
host harvey blankfeld of the blankfell
group at berkshire hathaway home
services and we have over a century of
collective experience
with me now in studio we have a special
guest we have rocky these here from
channel 8. welcome back rocky thank you
harvey
i'm feeling that bowtie yeah you know i
since i could tie a bow tie i wear a bow
tie it looks good it looks good now we
have a lot to cover
this is a really important topic it is
um it's all about disclosures
inspections in the seller's market
because sellers have to tell
people what's going on with their
property right yeah you know it's
you always have to as far as disclosures
are concerned in any market a seller
needs to be honest
be truthful in your disclosures don't
don't hide stuff because
if it's revealed later that you did hide
it it could cost you
three times the cost of repairs you just
don't want to do that just sleep well at
night knowing you disclose whatever
issues you've got
so i think for sellers to understand
that even even in a market that favors
them
they need to be diligent and thorough
and truthful in their disclosures very
importantly absolutely and what about
inspection wise
okay so it's funny in this market a lot
of buyers either at the suggestion of
their agent or
on their own impulse or deciding to
waive inspections which i'm again i have
a problem with that in the sense that
even though you may not ask for repairs
you'd like to know what's going on with
the house
i mean just and the seller shouldn't be
afraid of inspections the seller should
be
accommodating to inspections not that
you're going to ask for a bunch of stuff
to be done but just that you know what's
wrong if there is anything wrong and
there may be things
wrong with the home the seller's unaware
of right we've had issues in the past
where we had um
a broken roof truss and the seller never
knew it and and the
and when the buyer did the inspection
discovered it said we got a broken roof
trust
it was you know it was probably a seven
or eight hundred dollar repair so not
huge amount of money but enough to be
concerned because that roof
that's pretty important the roof is
important you need that we like we like
to have a roof it's important part of
the house yeah
exactly exactly what about minor repairs
though okay so look so when when you get
that inspection report and goes to the
buyer the buyer needs to understand that
in this market where it's very much
leaning towards a seller you may not get
the seller to do those minor repairs in
this market now in a market where it's a
little more neutral or maybe it's a
buyer's market
by all means give the seller a list of
repairs to knock out before closing
and let them do it but in this market
where the sellers are
are seeing that they have multiple
buyers and they have multiple offers and
they have
all kinds of opportunities to say yay or
nay they're probably going to say no to
most minor repairs and they might even
say no to major repairs but hopefully
not
but you need to be wary of that as a
buyer in the sense that
in a seller's favorite market they're
just not going to be excited about
spending more money it's a cutthroat
market
of course here especially right now
during this time what's going on over
the last three months we've seen our
inventory start to go up again
part of that might be because the
pandemic's coming to an end also
and so maybe um buyer buyers aren't
going to be as prevalent or readily
available because they're spending money
on other things now
right dinner vacations other items
besides just
you know basics so i think that that's
what's happening and hopefully we'll see
things become a little more neutral for
buyers
in the coming months for more
information
call 702-203-1165
or find them online at
lvrealestateradio.com
jc